we challenge 30 tables in this players
and if they can win one point against
all three of us they win 100 first round
[Music]
that was a good log oh this is
interesting
[Music]
[Applause]
my winning rate is is dropping all the
time 33 only
so it's pretty so far that have passed
okay hi welcome to the table okay
that's what I wanted
let's go
all right
on to the next round
that was crazy
I'm scared of this guy okay Emil good
luck
oh nice
the pressure is high yeah
[Music]
nice
oh sorry sorry
[Music]
what am I gonna do like that sir yes
nice
[Music]
foreign
that's the second time happens to me
ah nice
that was little one
this is going to be a very interesting
battle there's one slot first person who
can prove that they have subscribed to
pongfinity moves on to the next round
sometimes it pays off to be a subscribe
to pomfinity so if you haven't done that
yet remember to do it now so 15 players
from West Side got through level one
next they will face Mika to make to the
final boss
I'm feeling confident
[Applause]
is a bit intimidating there
[Music]
cleared the first one
foreign
makes a huge difference if I win the
serve I'm pretty confident but if I lose
the CERN anything can come from that
side okay I lost the surf
[Music]
pressure is so hot yeah like it's one
chance exactly it's brutal I ain't got
the sound watch out for the sir this is
a good one really fun foreign
[Music]
that's good that's good
very good well played good receiving
whoa ripping backpack take it easy
oh
foreign
Ty subscriber lucky subscribers
[Applause]
thank you
I'm gonna give her this up I'm so scared
thank you you're only one Survivor okay
so we have too many challenges and we'll
bring back four players all together the
first game was a bounce contest the last
two players bouncing would proceed to
the final we tried making it difficult
but players were passing even the
hardest challenges final spots were
decided with a sitting down race where
we saw some superhuman agility to secure
the first two spots in the final five
nice
[Applause]
the next game was simply to get the ball
into the box with some interesting
techniques and a solid Target short we
had two winners completing the final
five
okay so we have five people for the
final level the final boss the Sensei
now something never seen before
Oh my gosh
so made it to the final sir
oh yeah let's do it
whoever managed to win the point they
will win 100 dollars
prepare the final round
come on
that was crazy
thank you thank you sense again no mercy
at all there he loves Sensei you can
need it
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you
you never know
so that's on the line no pressure no
pressure
[Applause]
well done we have our first winner
that's yours thank you very much the
champion of west side table tennis La
Alfred congratulations
thank you